good morning tom how are you morning Dan
how the hell are you I'm great I'm great
I'm doing okay
I'm rehabbing a little bit from knee
replacement but I'm sorry partial knee
replacement but I'm I don't know how
Bella check would list me on the injured
list you know we'll put our injury put
on when the first game yes maybe right
now have you ever gotten the stare from
Bella check by asking a question the
inner circle yeah well you've gotten
that look like now it's a stupid
question but I'm going to insert this
one yeah they absolutely have that Matic
ain't that and you've got to play along
is there such a thing as a good question
to Belichick oh definitely absolutely
anything that talks about scheme
anything that talks about history
honestly when you ask a question that
rised hey look I don't know how this
works
explain it to me loves it how about if
you started the press conference is he
going to have one today he already did
he was great he was great what does that
mean he was great well look at my
Twitter feed and you'll see the story up
there that explains that he said look I
understand what the septal evaluators
out idiot but there's nothing going on
over the last few days so you guys are
able to tell us exactly who's meeting
but until we're playing real football I
can't do it so you guys are doing a
terrific job but not real action
football yet what if you said to
Belichick coach what would you like to
talk about today would you do that for
me one day yes
I'll plug whatever you have you know
I'll mention your name every five
minutes on the show but just say coach
Tom Curren Comcast SportsNet New England
what would you like to talk about today
you make me feel like I'm whoring myself
out would you do that for me I would do
that service figure yes or you would
okay all right what is the story in the
camp so far to me it's on a few
different micro level Spieth Rob
Gronkowski returning from his back story
ambience
it's Malcolm Butler setting aside his
business issues in competing the way is
it's the addition of Breanna crooks who
is 17 touchdown 2300 yard receive over
the last few years and Stephon Gilmore I
think there's a web link of its story on
the horizon because he had them in their
first days of camp might be saying you
know what I don't know really the bigger
story is the pursuit of 19 and Oh which
I don't think is just so we talk Thanks
but how did this start I don't know if
it's because they had a great offseason
I get that you're defending Super Bowl
champs but it almost feels like the
media is looking at this saying they
want this story to happen and I look at
the schedule there's a tough five-week
schedule or a stretch where they got
four road games I went it's really hard
to win like 12 or 13 games in the NFL
let alone to go 19 and oh here's the
reason I think it is likely okay it is
more likely than any other team has ever
been in the week they went 14 and one
with Brady in the center last year only
game they lost with Brady was Seattle
they were at the one-yard line with 30
seconds left and they didn't support tie
it so they went ostensibly could have
been 15 to know with Brady
not only that they beat the hell out of
two teams in the playoffs from the ASC
non-competitive games and didn't even
play well then the Super Bowl they spot
the NFC champions 25 points was twenty
three minutes left and they erased the
lead to that group they had Gronkowski
because he wasn't playing books and
Gilmore I mean when we talk about do you
think they're going 92 no I do
you all right I'll bet your dinner where
do you like to eat oh you can pick give
in to a ground round yeah okay I've been
to the Brown Derby before
I'll go to I'll go to Ponderosa okay
I'll do all of those things yeah but at
the Super Bowl in Minnesota I'll buy you
dinner if the Patriots are there and
they win and they go nineteen no because
I I don't have to happen on Monday
yeah after you're going to spend an
extra day in Minnesota yes I will I love
Minnesota in February okay
yeah but that's not going to I think it
he's a little depressed to talk about
the no not ludicrous I know that we're
look we haven't had a story to talk
about in the off season in the NFL like
what has been the big story we're trying
to make Kaepernick a big story this one
came along at a great time
all of a sudden USA Today goes you know
what the odds of them going nineteen
know Vegas puts out odds they're the
biggest favorites we've had in a long
long time to win the Super Bowl
everybody jumped on it because there's
nothing else to talk about if you had a
controversy in the NFL you know we had a
spider we had a deflate gate and then
you had the Kaepernick stuff
Ray Rice stuff there's been something we
haven't had anything in the offseason
the offseason has been owned by the NBA
not the NFL you're right and that's the
other interesting thing about this
training camp - this is the first time
since 2013 the Patriots of it has them
poop storm swirling around yeah 13 was
Hernandez Tim Tebow and they had well
her yeah that was well quick though 14
Revis came 15 to flake 8 16 to flake if
there's nothing that's going on in this
camp except for football that we aren't
supposed to evaluate yet I also I and
I'm probably the only person in the
media who believes this but I can see a
scenario where this is Tom Brady's last
year I don't think you're completely
high but I'm on my way it's unlikely
that it is okay because he really does
want play to like believe at least 43
years old and he keeps saying 45 or 50
but I think the family pressure I think
that's real town of every hotel I think
it's real and I think I don't know I
think
if he wins that Super Bowl and I handing
the trophy I think he says to me in
front of a hundred and fifteen million
people dan by the way you're right this
is it my final game good night everybody
yep if I would see it playing out that
way as well okay but the reason I say
that is don't know what family feels
like when your kids get to 11 and 9 7
different when they're 6 by 4 they're
portable they're all in the house once
you start feeling as if you're missing
things and maybe being a little bit
absent very important things I think
that starts the way on you don't you yes
I do but I also think if your kids get
to a certain age where they do get to
see dad play at a very high level it's a
pretty cool thing for dad his kids have
gotten to see him play where in the
jerseys watching the games and he's won
Super Bowls I do think there's something
to the Jews el part of this I really do
and I think if is I don't know if he's
going to try to play till he's 43 to
prove a point that this new health kick
and his diet Ninh is you know
nutritionist or trainer whoever that
they've tapped into something you know
the Fountain of Youth I could just see a
scenario where maybe this would be his
last year so I don't think you're crazy
okay
and by for the record I'm not high so
yeah it's early wake-and-bake Tom that's
what you do anything else you want to
talk about no that's unless there's
something else is on your mind
no I think the Kaepernick stuff McLovin
was talking about a minute ago was
interesting though some of the numbers
are bastardized and it is hard to bring
a guy in like a panic if he plays well
Flacco comes back and the we're
competing and the next thing you know
you have long term panic out there now
it's a nice taste back
Kaepernick can be as you pointed out in
Baltimore with the climate it can be a
football distraction he's too good to be
a backup in my estimation but you do you
think GM's and coaches say I want some
who's just sort of good enough at that
position yes man I do look you know you
know if someone comes available who
believes they're a starting player and
you bring them in or into them to stand
on the sidelines and watch at some point
you feel look I'm not going to satisfy
you with the role I have for you really
want to do that I also thought it was
interesting when Harbaugh said yesterday
we have to find out what his priorities
and interests are I thought that was the
most telling thing in terms of going
right up to is he interested in you know
being a spokesman at an activist or is
he interested in playing football yeah
and I think that's just yes I think that
that was the overriding feeling I got
yesterday with somebody who spoke to an
NFL owner to say his his side his agent
like they haven't pushed the issue of
him getting into camp now maybe the
Seattle was going to be a landing spot
or maybe Baltimore it doesn't feel like
they've been aggressive with this
they're almost waiting and it almost
feels like the more time that he is
viewed as an outcast or sacrificial lamb
or whatever it might be it emboldened
strengthens what his cause has been if
he goes and he gets into camping he's
just a backup quarterback and then
people move on from the topic then maybe
there's less talk about what his bigger
goal is and I think there's a concern is
he healthy and what is his mindset does
he really want to be a professional
football player so I think that's
happening in real time right now that's
a really good point because it does you
know pops up a little bit if somebody
hires them yes yes an OK because we move
on this is all generated by sports talk
and hot takes that that's all this is I
don't know if America is calling for
Colin Kaepernick to get on a roster but
host want to stir it up by saying see
being blackballed would your team take
him why wouldn't your team take him
isn't he better than your quarterback in
Cleveland or the Jets it's just sort of
everybody stirring the pot in a
different way and now we're trying to
add another recipe to this or another
ingredient and it's not happening we
thought it was going to happen with
Ravens not going to happen I guess so
let's talk about 19 oh you know what
every time I see you I'm just going to
ask you that's the only thing I'm going
to ask you how do you feel about 19 - no
I'm gonna ask you how you need and make
sure you bring it up - Bella check once
again way to get where you want to talk
about hey coach Tom Curren Comcast
SportsNet New England what do you want
to talk about today and I promise you
he's going to love that quiet it's going
to go really well for you Tom all right
well I think it will go better than you
think
okay say hi to sell this for me will you
okay say say hi to Tom Brady done okay
that's Tommy Kern at Comcast SportsNet
wing the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience